さあ皆さんやってまいりましたゴールデンウィークさん皆さん何をしますでしょうか
部活とがある人もいればお仕事の人もいるかもしれない
自炊恋暇な人もいるかもしれない通っても遊びに行く人もいるかもしれないが僕はです
ね
遊ぶ人がいません
ぼっちキャラとかそういうのじゃなくてリアルに遊ぶ人がいませんでした
後輩は実家に帰るし僕と同じ代の人はみんなも卒業して働いてて何か他の場所に行って
ですね実家の富山にも帰ってないし
あの
リアルぼっちですがちな方でちょっと遊び人がいないんですけども
せっかくこういうちょっとゆっくりできるよ今日はチョキで今日の動画ですねはじめの
のんびりこれでミークの1日
[音楽]
バチッ
ポテチな不況は一人でのんびりゆるくちょっと適当にバイクで行ってみようと思います
バイバーイ
[音楽]
[拍手]
に関わるよああ
分
着いたのはいいんですけどん
さすがゴールデンウィーク人が多くて恥ずかしいでござる
ベッツしているんだけど
変な目で見られてもこうなんかなんとかなる気がしてるんですよ
ずに自信を持っていきますああ俺変なことしてないからね
自分をとって自分の動画を出すというのが
木ですからね
あべし丸焼きにしずに行きましょうてこの大量の間続きの木があるにも関らず海が逆に
あるっていうのか
基本の松原でございます
どこおまつのきただけになってます
はインって
パッほらちょっともうねちょっと海が近いんですよ
おっ
多分俺は羽風呂本の松っていうところに行きたいんだから
こっちだなと行きたいところはね多分海沿いからでも行けるんねあとウェザーに行くと
人がたくさんいるからちょっと恥ずかしいんですよね
ましたこの後も心を鬼にしていくしかないということで
goo
[音楽]
ですが生んでね人が俺を見るかわかったよ
僕がある自撮り棒を使ってるんじゃなくて三脚を手に持って行ってから
ごついんですよね完全に治す丸大武器だぞ
もうねちょっとメンタルが落ち着いてきたから誰が3でてもたぶんねもう自撮りで全く
できる感じにまでもう来てるこっちがもう全部夏の木でこっちはもう海みたいな
これが日本の夏場の見どころです
やっぱりゴールデンウィークは結局カップルが多いんだなん
するんかな
違うねぇた分の1が少ないから
厚川に行きましょう定期的に位置取りしに外に出たほうがいいですね
1名がねやっても米デーみくてぃなやっぱで降った
うっすら富士山が見えます実は皆さんのおかげでチャンネル登録者の伸びが
たぶん今日本で一番すごいことになってるんですよ
でまぁそれに伴ってですね僕も結構
プレッシャーまあプレッシャーなきゃいけないんですけどもやっぱいろんな人が見て
くれるカラー
ちょっと頑張んなきゃって思っちゃってね
[音楽]
コーナーがちょっと面白い動画を取らなきゃ取らなきゃって思っちゃうことがあるん
ですけども
まあそれちょっと違うなと思いましていっ
昔はこういう動画も出してたんだよ
あんまり
腕に面白い動画を取らないけど何なキャットはもうよりー
やっぱり自分の撮りたいどうだとかね
ゆるーく誰で動画とかも必要だと思っていますこれからもちょっとこういうゆるい動画
を大切にして行かなきゃー
僕がちょっとダメになりそうなんで
皆さんこれからもゆ琉球よろしくお願いしますって感じですよ
大蛇とおやつも緩いのも無理したらば楽しくなくなっちゃうよね
うんんん
[音楽]
ん
分
[音楽]
うんん
car
ああああああ
松や杉元経営者なん
[音楽]
おっしゃ
me
[音楽]
さあ
ん
持った
お前の信じるかこれが俺がゴールデンウィークだ
だけどまだ土曜日だからー
まだこれから始まったばっかりなんだよ
弓道なんて本当にビックリしてるけど遊ぶ人がいます